you
as you lead us forward and fight for the
ideals that this land was actually
predicated on just just remember what
you're really fighting for is truth
justice and peace for all of us make
sure there's enough food for everybody
and make sure nobody is out on the
streets cold and that they all have a
home and then every is treated equally
when you overthrow the capital I want
you to feed us take care of the injured
bury the dead but the living needs you
to fix the education system and the
medical Obamacare fiasco that's
happening right now I think the people's
freedom people's voice are definitely
being muted and I would like to see you
fighting for people's rights
this is so I would like you to also
bring equality within all the different
classes within middle lower and upper
class katniss my advice for you is the
ditch Peter let him go and just go with
Liam Hemsworth that's it I would hope
you would fight for quality and so we
all have a equal chance we really need
to get a hold on all the gangs that are
going on throughout all the big cities I
mean the poor are getting poorer and the
rich are getting richer and that needs
to change because while the rich are
sitting on golden toilets there's people
out there that are still hungry make
life affordable and easy for everyone in
a way that everyone can live everyone
can be sheltered there's no rich nor
poor but everyone has everything in
common trust myself every heart vibrates
to that iron string just be true to
yourself no matter what